hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com so in this video guys we
gonna go through the price action on amc
on gme we're gonna discuss triple q the
u.s 10-year yield that is still above
285 so the situation is still
very
risky to me anything can happen
and i'm also gonna show you something
cool about amazon so let's get into it
alright as usual guys amc
gme what's happening here so
we are still in this descending wedge on
amc
uh this is what we are monitoring so
this morning i really
thought
that we might have finally this second
bullish signal that combined with the
bullish signal we already have on the
first time frame which is
uh
sorry bullish divergence all right
momentum going higher price action
making lower lows momentum making higher
lows all right
bam bam bam
uh
so here it is all right higher higher
lower so we are waiting once again let
me remind you guys and i showed you that
in my discord this morning i had a good
question
about uh
where is it about dkng
so basically this was the situation dkng
you guys can go and check they have
earnings coming soon and a member asked
me is it a good time to buy because he
saw there is a bullish divergence and i
explained like i did
uh in my course and a few times in
discord but uh it's still good to say it
again that the bullish divergence
creates a bullish signal whenever it is
combined with one more bullish signal
that needs to come from the price action
the bullish divergence comes from the
momentum so it needs to come from the
price action so for example the
candlestick pattern so here we almost
had a bullish angle thing it can be a
hammer like we said before it can be an
sma crossover it can be an rsi below
than 50 as you can see here the rsi is
at 40 let me show that in real
sorry i switched from amc because amc is
in the same situation like many uh
stocks right now are in a descending
wedge and so we have bullish divergences
on many stocks
uh but
for a bullish divergence to give you a
signal you need to associate it with one
of those four all right here the rsi as
you can see is still at
43 the rsi must be checked on the same
time frame you see the bullish
divergence all right think about it
and or a breakout so you have four
different signals that you can combine
to have a
signal to buy and here for now we don't
have any of those we almost had here a
bullish engulfing as you can see
yesterday's move plus fifteen percent
uh plus ten percent sorry almost
engulfed the candle before
so this is close to be a bullish
engulfing so this is almost a
reason to get in this is what i said
so let's back to amc
we are waiting for the same kind of
thing we have the bullish divergence not
on the daily we have it on the four
hours we doesn't with that which doesn't
change anything you just stay in the
four hours and you take the same thing
on the first time frame right the
candlestick depends on the time frame
the rsi depends on the time frame the
moving average crossover depends on the
time frame
um
only the breakout doesn't depend on the
time frame but most of the signals that
you need to combine are going to be
checked
i mean it's important to see on the same
time frame and it works for every time
frame higher than 30 minutes so here
uh bam bam bam
you can see the rsi is very weak
on the time frame we have the divergence
at 37 so it shows us that
we are not yet ready to really uh be
bullish but
here we having this breakout that is
really close to happen
uh i need to readjust a little bit
but i can see i have the 20 uh period
moving average just here so basically
you know we have a double resistance the
trend line and the moving average so
what we want is both of these um
resistances to be crossed over with a
close above the 20 period moving
averages on the first time frame which
is right now at 15.35 so i was
monitoring that this morning and ready
to buy and of course
and send a signal of course in my
discord and here we got unfortunately
rejected so i didn't sell and didn't
send any alert on this and i didn't take
any position
i'm waiting i'm waiting for that and for
now if we go lower i mean i'm happy i'm
gonna buy lower that's it and the shares
i have one day i'm gonna sell them
higher
two so i'm fine with the price action
going lower i have a plan for that and
once this happens guys we're gonna
discuss everything we're gonna need to
see if we break out here doing a plus
three percent
uh which is not strong or if we break
out with a plus fifteen percent which is
strong and we're gonna need to see what
is happening on the rest of the market
and on the u.s 10 year yield and the dx
y all right everything needs to be uh on
the in going going to the same um
conclusion
otherwise a squeeze will not happen
jamie
so jimmy broke out below the 61.8
percent uh february show yesterday i
told you guys this was the level i
checked on amc and i told you that after
that level was broken it was at 21. it's
gonna be hard for this third wave to
develop same thing for jimmy now uh
so i think we are going 205 this is what
i said yesterday in my video just
looking at jme
because i have no support before that
but you know it happens many times that
we have a rebound that is not on the
support so it can still go higher but
for now buzzing control and next support
105. uh then what we are monitoring here
is this trend line but like i said it's
not perfect so here yes this is what i
said yesterday
you can see the trend line to check is
here because yeah but basically i'm
gonna say what i said yesterday but you
can see consolidations uh on gme
happen
uh sideways okay sideways sideways on
amc it's not sideways all right it's
dropping
so it's good and not good but just keep
in mind that here the strength line is
not the one we want to break out above
it's this level okay 130 130 all right
so we need jme to trade above 130 for
boost to take back control on the short
term
then triple q
uh
we are really hovering around this 318
level uh this is the situation to me
uh bam bam bam
so we might very well
go you know rebound or go lower i don't
know i hear and personally don't have i
mean i have a short position on triple
cube because it protects me on my other
investments i'm flatish uh
i mean i made a little bit of money on
the way down
but i'm rather flatish um here overall
i'm waiting to have more information
here i wait for rebound if i have a
rebound i will sell it rema i remind you
guys what i said yesterday we are
looking for one two three four five here
right and i i i
hope the third way the fifth wave won't
go here but it's possible maybe it's
gonna be a shallow fifth and then we're
going to have abc and then more downside
but
based on control guys all right base and
control as long as we are below this red
resistance 338 to me which is the pivot
point that we need to trade above to
close above even on a weekly time frame
guys one day is not enough for boost to
take back control all right and it needs
to happen on
decent volume because we know the volume
will be lower on the way up as it always
is whenever we have
as you can see here a rebound but it
needs to be strong enough here the
volume was too weak for this to be
really a reversal all right so we're
gonna pay attention to that for now
bears and control once again i don't
take a bearish position here if triple
two goes to so basically four or five
percent higher which is on the sp why
because some of you are asking me can
you i mean why do you check triple q and
not spy it's same guys all right you
just need to have an indicator of the
global market i use triple q i mean
i can use spy guys as you're gonna see i
have my charts here as well they're
gonna tell me pretty much the same thing
uh i just have good signals on triple q
so this is what i'm checking now
uh i prefer to stay on triple two but
it's same all right and here as long as
triple q is below 338 guys bears are in
control all right so for me uh this is a
market where
uh every bounce needs to be sold so that
we have protection we make money on the
way down and we can reload lower what
are the levels to reload as before for
now it has not changed
it's around 280.
uh then the u.s tenure yield as you guys
know this is representing the expected
rate
the expected return of of equity the
higher ideas uh the more investors will
um
will think it's hard to make money on
equity
and now we have we are 40 years break
out above this trend line all right 40
years resistance that is breaking out i
had my friend from goldman sachs this
morning
uh over the phone and i told him so
what's up bro what are you doing because
i know that you guys are gonna start to
tell your clients to afford so
i should not give my friend's name of
course
because it's a bit sensitive information
i mean whatever but what he told me is
that um
yes
they start to think that uh
that it's time to
offload some positions on the equity
market and to buy bonds but
inflation is at eight percent right i
mean it's not going to be a yearly
inflation of eight percent but monthly
it's eight percent
so if you go to bones you're sure 100
sure that you're not gonna beat
inflation so basically your
uh return adjusted with infl inflation
is minus five percent so basically you
put your money here but you lose
uh
real power
of money i mean
so real
i mean you
in reality you can buy less in 10 years
that you could buy
[Music]
that you could buy now
that's the reality with an inflation at
8 percent so the only way to beat
inflation is the equity market and
that's why that's what he told me
so they said that they're not gonna
offload yet
uh because i still at least they have a
chance to beat um the inflation by
betting on the equity but he also told
me that the equity is still
overvalued for most of companies all
right we are still in a kind of bubble
all right because of all this money
printing and investors being so
confident that markets will just rally
forever
that
uh that he told me that yeah most most
of companies are overvalued uh compared
to their um do they expect to the
expected returns in five ten years
um
and that's uh
yeah and another thing is that whenever
the rates are going higher you guys know
that to know the value theoretical value
of a company you're gonna check
what are the cash flows for the next 10
years and you're going to adjust this
with the um
you're going to discount those cash
flows with the rates so if it's a
10-year cash cash flow it's going to be
a 10-year rate
true
whenever you discount the higher the
rate the lower the discounted value so
basically when rates go up this
um valuation method gives lower values
for companies which means that a 10-year
that is gonna rally
is mechanically gonna impact the
valuation of many many companies
especially the companies that don't make
money today but that expect to make
money in five ten years so all the you
know innovative companies uh meme stocks
for example are some of them so a tenure
that is rallying is really bad from him
stocks so once again let's keep an eye
on that and if there is
a correction here
then we breathe
and
let's see where is the equity market i
think that if the tenure comes back to
two the equity market will
be very high already but if it's not the
case then it's of course a good
opportunity to buy
last thing for today guys amazon
uh i sent an alert this morning i'm very
careful with my alerts i mostly send
bearish alerts i mean
i mean i send
i i do a lot of updates on uh bearish
trades on triple q for protection
because i think that we are in a
situation and i'm doing that for the
past six months i mean four or five
months
because we are in a bearish environment
so i want my members to be aware that
there is some way to get protection but
i also keep you know sending alerts on
uh
for those who want to buy the dip and
here this is a nice situation it's
amazon so they lost
uh 10 yesterday or how much
not yesterday two days ago fourteen
percent uh because of supply chain
issues
uh that is you know impacting their um
their
their revenues not their revenues but
their profits and uh and a lower demand
because you know the coveted crisis is
almost behind us so people i mean not in
china but you know in the rest of the
world so people are more going to buy
things in reality than on the internet
so it's so they have lower demand on
amazon and higher costs because of
inflation and because of uh supply chain
uh disruption so basically their profits
uh declined a lot
here
uh
they you know 190 percent
less than expected i'm not sure how to
read that but basically they're they had
really bad results
so
the volume increased as you can see a
lot here
all right
so this is not good this is what i call
a risk right so my chat was like that
okay
but whatever
it's not where it should be okay uh
because it shows that bears are taking
back control on a move like that but we
are coming with a weekly ah because it
was on the weekly timeframe
okay
we are coming
on the weekly
oversold rsi i checked it's the first
time i see this i mean it happened here
as well
what happened here i didn't see that
let's check that together bam bam bam
all right
rebound rebound alright so each time you
have a weekly no okay here you had one
this one didn't work
okay so you can see here weekly oversold
and then we lost
rsi ever sold we lost 23 all right so
sometimes you after weekly oversold rsi
we saw some strong moves down and then
again oversold and then the second one
the second time was the good one so
maybe we are in the situation
or maybe we are in this situation same
thing oversold and then second time
oversold again and then rebound so
maybe it needs to be oversold twice i
don't know here we are coming we have a
weekly oversold rsi combined once again
guys you always need to combine those uh
signals indicators otherwise you're
going to have a lot a lot of fake
signals but this is a good combination
trend line that has not been touched for
quite some time plus oversold rsi this
is a good combination so this is if i
just if i don't pay attention to the
volume or to the situation this is a buy
but
the volume here is increasing a lot
so that's
already a reason not to get in i
personally don't get in but it's still
an opportunity to buy we can very well
bounce strongly and rally or
we can bounce a little bit
like we're doing right now
and just break out all right so
if this happens if here we have a nice
consolidation
um
like i explained in my course
then
you can sell this bracket if we go right
away then better to wait for a re-test
that is here the red scenario and to buy
puts here so this would be in one or two
months if this happens
this is bad all right but here i would
be personally buying protection
so that's it for today i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget guys to click on this sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys